y
[Música]
último debate rumbo a las elecciones
presidenciales estadounidenses donald
trump y joe biden compartirán escenario
en nashville y para evitar
interrupciones los organizadores han
impuesto una nueva regla los micrófonos
se silenciarán cuando no se les haya
dado la palabra la pandemia la economía
y las tensiones raciales estarán entre
los temas a debatir
luis almagro debe renunciar sus manos
están manchadas de sangre de bolivianos
así pide la renuncia a evo morales- del
secretario general de la organización de
los estados americanos organismo que
presentó un informe en su contra tras
los comicios presidenciales del 2019 que
derivaron en la salida del poder del ex
mandatario de bolivia
europa intenta frenar el avance de la
segunda ola de la pandemia francia
registró otro nuevo récord de casos
diarios y extendió los toques de queda a
cerca de dos tercios de su población y
en españa' el ministro de la salud dijo
que la pandemia estaba fuera de control
en muchas áreas por lo que considera una
acción similar tenemos reporte desde
parís
[Música]
hola cómo están bienvenidos a las
noticias aquí en france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria y empezamos en eeuu y es
que donald trump y joe biden ya están en
nashville para su último debate antes de
las elecciones del 3 de noviembre será
un encuentro marcado por el atropellado
cara a cara que los dos candidatos
protagonizaron en ohio a finales de
septiembre ahora con unos micrófonos que
podrán silenciar se vai de nitro me
quieren aprovechar una enorme pantalla
para así conseguir los votos de los
indecisos vamos a este informe de juan
pop ya les
un presidente que ya sabe cómo ganar sin
ser favorito su rival un candidato que
aventaja en las encuestas pero siempre
ha sido de la eterna aspirante el
presidente de la cndh tranvía el
candidato presidencial demócrata joe
biden ya están en nashville para su
último debate antes de las elecciones la
universidad de belmondo acoge el segundo
y último debate presidencial de la
campaña en esta ocasión con unos
micrófonos que podrán cerrarse por parte
de la moderadora para evitar episodios
caóticos como el del primer cara a cara
serán seis temas el hobbit 19 la familia
estadounidense la carrera política el
cambio climático la seguridad nacional y
el liderazgo by the night' trump tendrán
dos minutos para ello solos en cada una
de sus primeras respuestas sobre estos
temas antes de su partida a nashville
padre había dejado claro su mensaje
esperemos que él juegue según las reglas
esperemos que les hayan hecho la prueba
a todos esperemos que ya esté todo
arreglado
trump por su parte ya libre del joven 19
que impidió que participara en otro
debate dejó claro que sus reglas no son
las de todos el mandatario compartió una
entrevista con el programa sixty minutes
de cbs antes de la fecha prevista de
estreno argumentando que el programa no
era objetivo y buscaba atacarlo usted va
a obtener equidad pero está de acuerdo
con unas preguntas difíciles no no está
de acuerdo con unas preguntas difíciles
voy a ser franco usted no le hace
preguntas difíciles a bailén el último
debate a sólo 12 días de las elecciones
y aunque ya más de 40 millones de
estadounidenses han votado de manera
anticipada que se cara a cara se muestra
como una oportunidad clave ante los
estados pendulares aquellos en donde no
siempre gana el mismo partido
acompáñenos esta noche en un especial
sobre él cara a cara entre los
aspirantes a la casa blanca- joe biden y
donald trump a las 8 de la noche hora de
volta ciudad de mexico quito y lima con
la total cobertura en directo del último
debate entre ambos candidatos y al
finalizar el análisis con mi compañero
santiago lópez invitados y nuestros
corresponsales en eeuu y seguimos en
este país y es que el comité judicial
del senado liderado por republicanos
aprobó la nominación de amy cón y
barrett para ocupar la vacante vitalicia
de la corte suprema de justicia-
despejando así el camino para que el
pleno ratifique la próxima semana la
elección de la nominada por donald trump
esto pese al boicot planteado por los
demócratas del comité en protesta por la
rapidez en que se realizó el proceso
grupos de manifestantes se movilizaron
frente al capitolio entre las
manifestantes se pudo ver algunas
mujeres vestidas como personajes de la
serie de televisión cuentos de la criada
que trata de los derechos de las mujeres
y es que los opositores temen que
barrett sea un retroceso en temas
conservadores como el aborto en noticias
de bolivia el ex presidente evo morales
pidió la renuncia de luis almagro como
secretario general de la organización de
los estados americanos la oea organismo
que presentó un informe en su contra
tras acusaciones de fraude en los
comicios presidenciales anulados hace un
año
morales quien se exilió en argentina por
presiones del ejército y protestas
opositoras dijo que llevará el caso a la
corte penal internacional y que almagro
y su equipo deben ser procesados
horas antes el organismo aseguró que el
triunfo de luís arce fue claro en estas
últimas presidenciales en las que el
organismo dice no presenció
irregularidades luís al mal 9 denuncia
sus manos están manchadas de sangre de
bolivianas y bolivianos
luisa la mano no tiene autoridad moral
para dirigir los destinos de la oea
si no lo hacen yo le citó a los estados
miembros de la oea que inicien al amparo
de los artículos 116 de la carta de la
oea los trámites pertinentes para dar
destitución de louis armado de su puesto
de secretario general
porque ha ocasionado un daño irreparable
al pueblo boliviano a medida que
aumentan los casos y los servicios de
salud se ven sometidos a una mayor
presión en europa algunos gobiernos
vuelven a extremar medidas para frenar
el rebrote de la pandemia que ya deja
más de 256.000 muertos en este
continente en españa- el ministro de
salud salvador y ya dijo que el kobe 19
estaba ahora fuera de control en muchas
áreas pero el gobierno no logró imponer
nuevas restricciones tras desacuerdos
con las autoridades regionales mientras
que el gobierno francés se anunció que
el toque de queda impuesto la semana
pasada en parís y en otras ocho ciudades
se extendería a 38 departamentos más
confinando así a 46 millones de los 67
millones de habitantes del país son
cerca de dos tercios de la población
horas después de que se anunciaran estas
medidas francia registró 41 mil 622
nuevos casos en 24 horas otro nuevo
récord diario sobre las nuevas medidas
nos dio los detalles desde la capital
francesa a natalia
francia está en una situación grave en
noviembre será un mes extenuante y las
muertes seguirán aumentando ese fue el
tono de la conferencia de prensa que dio
ron castex el primer ministro de francia
en la tarde de este jueves acompañado de
alguno de sus ministros el primer
ministro galo anunció una ampliación del
toque de queda a 38 departamentos más a
partir de la medianoche de este viernes
y una medida pues que regirá a partir
del sábado de 9 de la noche a 6 de la
mañana por espacio de seis semanas con
este anuncio ya son 54 los departamentos
en donde hay un 'toque de queda' además
de la polinesia francesa y 46 millones
de habitantes que se ven afectados por
esta medida
castex él dijo que para frenar esta
epidemia se necesita la de trabajo de
todos y que de no ser así pues va a va a
tener que tomar unas medidas mucho más
duras el ministro de salud también
aprovecho para tomar la palabra durante
esta rueda de prensa y dijo que se
espera la próxima semana se haga una
evaluación de la eficacidad o no de esta
medida de toque de queda también se
presentó rápidamente la aplicación de
rastreo para coronavirus una nueva
aplicación mucho más personalizada y en
la que se podrán consultar datos diarios
de la epidemia a nivel nacional y a
nivel local por último esta vez si se le
dé un poco de importancia al sector de
la cultura uno de los más afectados por
estas medidas de especial del toque de
queda la ministra de cultura- joslin
bucks lo estaba presente y anunció
ayudas suplementarias por 115 millones
de euros para las salas de cine los
espectáculos los autores y los técnicos
vamos con las protestas en nigeria que
se han intensificado desde el miércoles
cuando grupos de manifestantes y
policías armados se enfrentaron en
algunos barrios después de un tiroteo el
día anterior amnistía internacional
señala que soldados y la policía han
disparado a los manifestantes en lagos
dejando al menos 12 muertos el ejército
nigeriano ha negado que sus soldados
estuvieran en el lugar del tiroteo donde
las movilizaciones se llevan a cabo en
desafío al toque de queda
el presidente muhammadu buhari pidió que
cesen las agresiones y que dialoguen con
el gobierno
[Aplausos]
cambio la página y finalizamos con el
premio sájarov y es que la oposición de
belarús fue galardonada por su trabajo
en favor de los derechos humanos el
anuncio llega después de más de dos
meses de manifestaciones en contra del
presidente alexander lukashenko quien
lleva más de 26 años en el poder y que
el 9 de agosto fue reelecto en unos
comicios que opositores señalan como
fraudulentos la oposición es liderada
por la ex candidata del clan nati cano
sky a quien dedicó el premio a la
ciudadanía
pues así llegamos al final de esta
emisión les agradecemos mucho su
compañía los invitamos a que sigan con
nosotros ya que se cuide cuídense mucho
del cobi 19
[Música]